anywho watching uh genia's episode dude
episode two is great so good man catches
you up to speed yeah so [ __ ] good
yeah
it's like the best documentary i think
i've ever seen
yeah everyone
you know i saw a few comments from the
last episode a lot of people were really
keen on clarifying
he's the goat at music but not a good
person it's like well that kind of
that is obvious dude
what like these early [ __ ] recordings
of him do not account for his present
actions like when you just look at his
music career in isolation like yeah no
[ __ ] like
i'm just saying people are pointing out
the obvious like i don't know why people
feel the need to like clarify because we
were like i don't but i don't think that
i think it proves the opposite doesn't
it what that he's not a bad person
um i mean oh yeah no if you're asking me
personally yeah i'm just saying when you
look at because what we were talking
about is like
how decorated his career was so early in
his life and like the path he took was
so wild
that has nothing to do with what he's
done in the last 10 years it's like when
you're we're talking about that in
isolation oh yeah people just feel the
need to be like yeah but he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] now it's like that's not even
what we were talking yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know
irritated me but yeah yeah and and
i have to like follow up and say damn
like when you look at all the people
that were around him like
through that and through episode two and
like through that journey like holy [ __ ]
yeah like we had no idea obviously yeah
that's the whole point of documentary
but
um
that i the [ __ ] the nerd in me was so
hyped on the
through the wire music video i had no
idea that they tracked that [ __ ] with
post-its bro yeah
[ __ ] hell no
cold dude and filmed it for like months
yeah
oh
and
there was a comment in there i don't
know if you caught this when cootie gets
in the bmw there's that girl picking
them up
and he like pops in and he's like hey
what's up and she's like oh are you like
a you a filmmaker and he's like yeah and
she's like you go with final cut yeah i
was like that must have been literally
final cut one yeah yeah like whoa
whoa yep
and then and then he was like yeah i'm
not i'm not too good with editing i'm
just you know i got the vision
and
i think about then like
the discipline of like videographer and
editor
was definitely not as common yeah you
know you're probably just one or the
other oh yeah which makes that video way
crazier yeah right yeah well and there's
all the right they have to go they'd go
into like mtv and use their computer
yeah because they were the only ones
like with the resources to do that
probably with a computer powerful enough
yeah exactly all that and one dude who
knows how to do a [ __ ] transition or
whatever yeah and yeah and like and the
just the tracking the tracking yeah
now it's it's so crazy how assumptive
everyone is with editing it's like oh
you can just track that yeah yeah
yeah
man
yeah i mean
that was dope
um
just seeing all the people he brought in
like from chicago like d-ray davis and
and all that like i didn't even realize
d-ray davis did that sketch in college
dropout yeah
so
yeah and um
i don't know the end i haven't heard
that that sound on tick tock his grammy
speech yeah i've also never seen it oh
what picture me for the first time what
after that documentary or after that
episode sorry like i was already like
holy [ __ ] because it really accelerates
at the end is success and everything
that you've been waiting
for to happen for the first four hours
of this documentary finally happens and
it's like all of a sudden it's like whoa
whoa boy he becomes super famous and
then he said speech at the grammys and
i'm sitting there like what's he gonna
say yeah
and that he just
murders it
that end i started crying yeah i
actually started crying i was sitting on
the couch with tears in my eye and then
kelsey's like you ready and i'm like
yeah dinner let's go
i guess we'll never i'm not hungry
anymore i guess we'll never know never
know yeah it was so sick
holds up the statue [ __ ] yeah sick yeah
yeah um but then fast forward to present
day he did his donda 2 concert last week
i watched
i watched it too
i mean i watched the replay yeah and
then i watched like because i saw like
redder was going crazy about how bad the
oh yeah audio mixing was at the end do
we have some cl oh i guess we gotta no
we can't yeah we gotta watch it um yes
in the bonus episode but like everyone
was
they were like oh my god r.i.p to the
guy's name who engineered it yeah and i
guess he deleted his instagram i watched
it in real time yeah
and it was crazy how fast
people like were with it like as soon as
the credits world i like refreshed my
twitter and i saw a tweet i don't even
know how it had that many [ __ ]
retweets and it was just like r.i.p to
these guys it was the whole sound team
and uh
you know
it was like uh first of all that cardy
[ __ ] when he came out like
like when he came out and did his
i was dying
yeah
yeah this is actually kind of cool
i [ __ ] with this ep man poor five yo man
i know doing everything in his play he's
just trying to be a performer yep he's
just showing up to do the job yeah man
you know i'm trying to make the best of
this really trying to [ __ ] stay on
beat
and alicia keys too yeah she was like
the only one who was like her sounded
decent yeah but yeah fabio was
is that who is that one of the audio
engineers he just posted on his story
wasn't me
i mean i would imagine that has nothing
to do with like
the engineering that has to be like a
like a technical thing like with the
receivers or whatever because it just
seems like their in-ear monitors went
out and there's water so they can't have
floor monitors
so now they have no way to monitor
and perform yeah but but
wouldn't you try to have some redundancy
or just something to make sure that that
that's the one thing that can't happen
right there but that's what i mean [ __ ]
shuts off then it's like i mean that's
another thing that can't happen but like
at least then it's like oh technical
difficulties you're trying to get it
back up but for that's just the song to
sound [ __ ] horrible like it did
because no one can rap on beat yeah like
worst case scenario no i know you have
some like system
yeah well i guess that's what i'm saying
is like i don't know if that's
necessarily the
engineering aspect so much as like a
tech aspect where
whoever
which should have been like oh no we
need you know whatever like
setting up some kind of redundancy some
kind of fail-safe yeah that's typically
what happens because you know like we
like even the shows we've done like
wireless has gone out and so we have
like those
corded mics like why you know it there
probably was some [ __ ] creative
battle where they were telling them like
yo bro like
we won't have any fail safes that
probably was what it was like
we can't put a wired mic out there
because it's water and he's like that's
fine
so it might have been just
a [ __ ] awful like
you know okay if this happens we're
[ __ ] yeah and then it happened and
then everyone up there is like filling
out their resume
because the [ __ ] just happened yeah
um
but yeah you said you said their in-ear
monitors stopped working
that way oh so they were trying to wrap
i think that's what they were doing
yeah
like they're transferrable yeah holy
[ __ ] like i think
i may be i might be misremembering but i
swear like five year old would like dish
out a few lines and then he was probably
getting the feedback
and now it's like [ __ ] with his head
just saying anything you know when
you're on a zoom meeting and there's an
echo yeah and it just [ __ ] with your
brain i think that's exactly what it was
like
yeah wow
yeah anyways and his his album was
supposed to come out right didn't come
out it came out it came out on those
little things yeah so those are out in
people in the pup in the wild right now
i mean everyone i've said i've seen like
talk about it so like it just feels
really unfinished
the album
so people actually have those little
stem players i think so
like they've arrived in the mail and
people either that or like maybe you can
sign up like you can buy the product and
then there's something somewhere online
you can listen to it
so it's not gonna be on spotify i don't
think so
yeah
seems like an odd choice
i mean
from a guy who is
clearly you know after like you watch
genius you're like this guy does not
care about convention yeah or i know
rules but didn't he post some
something like one of his posts
regarding this and his apple music deal
was that he didn't want to be
owned or something or
we should own we should control the
creative and the pipeline and all that
stuff but yeah they were gonna pay him
100 million bucks
yeah it's like well
i don't know man
i mean who knows like you got the best
of that deal
yeah but then he turned it down
and sold a stem player instead well i'm
sure he's filming like the other
eight hours of his second documentary
right now
yeah i mean which i will watch yeah
what a man
i mean dude he i he is an artist in the
truest sense you know he polarizes
people as far as like what he's done
um
you know some [ __ ] obvious some not so
much like
[Music]
you